hello everyone uh welcome to the adzen
university virtual training symposium
my name is takashi kondo and i'll be
hosting today's session
today we are presenting hplc tips and
tricks presented by joanne long
just a little housekeeping before we get
started
if you have any questions during the
presentation
please type them into the question box
in your control panel
we'll bring them up during the q and a
session at the end
now we will turn the time over to joanne
hello everyone today i'm going to share
with you some of the hblc tips and
tricks in this webinar
so the objective of today's uh will give
you some ideas about everyday hplc
troubleshooting
i believe that some of you are that has
been using hplc has already had an idea
or what maybe need to take note but for
today
sharing i want to start with like what
is this important to know your baseline
operating parameters if changes occur it
will make it easier for a troubleshoot
if you look at this
like here during the course of your work
things that you really need to monitor
is including like pressure so later i
will go more in depth about uh what are
the pleasure parameters that you really
need to take note of
baseline noise retention time positions
area positions peak height precision
peak shape and sensitivity i believe
that these are also the parameters that
you are actually monitoring during doing
your system suitability testing
i believe that you will definitely have
questions like uh is the problem related
to application method or the instrument
so in that situation you may considering
injecting the standard
mix into the hardware that you are
currently using
for the particular methods
that you think that uh the results
is not as expected
when you inject the standards into
the hbrc you will also need to use the
column that is
reliable a new column or the column that
you always use it for the standard
injections the purpose of it is to find
out whether the
the abnormal peak shape may do to the
instruments or the application itself
so what you can do is that you need to
have a hbrc test sample that you always
use to check your equipment
or you can use agilent hvac checkout
standard as what our engineers usually
do which there is the four pigs and then
these are the compounds that are
chemically stable
in its sufficient concentration then
usually you will use the test column
like um
the c18 column
that every the recorded length internal
diameter or even stationary phase and
the particle size so we are using the
normal column that you usually use check
out the instruments
it can help you to have less variations
when you want to compare again when the
instrument is in good condition
of course the separation methods are
also very important solvents that are
used flow rate temperature pressure even
detection temperatures all are the
standard methods
that you usually use to check the
instrument which ultimately it should
give you the the results that you want
which including the peak that you
expected to see resolution peak areas
thickness to noise
and etc
if you are coming from a palma company
these are usually the qualification
protocol that usually our engineer will
use to test on the instrument condition
okay now next let's look at what are the
instruments modules that give you
what kind of possible problems and how
can you troubleshoot from it
as you see from the slide here the top
part is the sovereign border
it's the same as what we have uh
beside me here which is the hblc
sovereign border
followed by
um in this example here we actually have
this author sampler
and then
um
thermostat column compartment and the
detector
the one that you see on the slides are
in the orientation of
solvent and then followed by detector
column compartment sampler and pump
with this flow here
both are optimized it depends on
your lab conditions some may prefer to
have one set some may prefer to have two
sets depending on the height of your
bench and depending on the left sop
condition
but most important is auto sampler and
palm should come after one another
and then the
auto sampler with column compartments
should also come with one another so
opal sampler could be in them in between
of a pump
and a column compartment the last one
has to be a detector because that is for
detection purposes
so in this
slide examples that show in the slides
the solvent will actually go down to the
palm then it starts to flow upwards to
the auto sampler
where it control the injection volume
to be introduced into the column
and then followed by the column
compartment
where that is the heart of the whole
hblc
where these columns will help with the
separation so compounds that
retain stronger onto the column will
tend to elude up later but compounds
that does not retain that long in the
column made it lift up earlier and this
helped with the
separation of the pit
and then lastly
the compound will get illustrated from
the column and then flow to the detector
this is where detection happens
that is when it is in a one-step
condition
why the pump may be at the lower part it
could be because of that palm is very
heavy so it really depends on the lab
situation and the lab condition but in
this example here still the palm is at
the lowest because it's heavier but in
this case because of two stacks what
happens is
the solvent will flow to the pump and
then the palm go upward to the auto
sampler
sideways to the column compartment
so we want to have a
minimal
kind of
tubing length and then from column
compartment here the column inside but
then to the detector
this is the flow of it
and this also
will ensure that you will have a optimal
result which able to give you a
reproducible retention time which is a
key
parameters for you to identify the
compound because imagine when the two
peaks standard pink and the sample pigs
you mentioned that are not similar you
may thinking whether this is the right
compound that is being detected or that
is something that is unknown
okay next we really want to look into
the type of problem that we usually face
so pleasure problems fall into one of
the three categories
high pressure low pressure or even
fluctuating pressure a pressure problem
can occur
suddenly or gradually
what does it mean or suddenly suddenly
means that when your
particles from the tempers actually
block your columns or damage
the tubing
when they actually flow through the
system
the pressure will suddenly shoot up
that is when um there are some particles
are being
in the system
gradual pressure it could be the
um
precipitation so the precipitation
actually slowly build up
or the particles generated in the
instrument their breath may be coming
from your wildcatter or your some of the
degrading seals so all these are slowly
build up along the time
so and that's how it happens with a
gradually increase in pressure
now we would want to go into pleasure to
hyphen because that is the most common
problem that you usually face compared
to a
low back pressure
or
fluctuating
pressure
okay so now i will
go into i'm showing you on the real
hardware itself so that you have this
better idea where could be the cause of
the high back pressure
on the instrument
whatever you see in the slideshow these
are the guidelines uh which including
like column inlets with contaminations
of column
contaminator free first shrub
contaminated
capillary and etc so now i want to go
into the equipment by itself
i will go into the instrument now
to show you which are the parts that
usually cause high back pressure but
before that i will also want to go
through with you the flow of the solvent
so you can connect between the flow of
the solvent and the cost of
this high blood pressure in each of the
components in this hplc
what you see here is the mobile phase
usually the movavi that being used are
organic solvents and water so the
organic solvent that usually being used
could be like acetonitrile methanol or
anaesthetic
whereas for the water content it could
be pure water or it could be a stock
bucket so the salts like phosphate
buffer all these are being mixed
together with the water
it because it may give you a better
separation
so when you have a hot buffer
with the acetone nitrile being used as a
mobile phase you will really need to
take note on
the high back pressure that may due to
the precipitation of this salt because
your water contains salt butter
when it is in its own bottle
precipitation may not happen
precipitation may only happen
when both these solvents are both
solvents and salt buffers are mixed
together
because organic solvents and pot buffers
they are
they don't really like each other so
when you have high organic solvent
content like 80 of it and only 20
percent of
the spot buffer
then you may start to see precipitation
in these mixtures or if it flows through
the system
then
start along the line or in the
components of this hplc
when the foreign flow through
where the mixing happened the mixing
happened at the
arm
so the solver will first flow into the
palm
from this individual
solvent tubing
and go into this multi-channel gradient
valve this multi-channel gradient valve
will draw
the solvent ratio based on what you have
set in your software
and then the mixing would then happen at
the outlet
of this tubing
so when the mixing happens from here
onwards and then to the palm head
they flow into the inlet while here if
you look at this this is the inlet wow
and then followed by the two piston
inside the palm head
outlet wow
and then they may go into the
[Music]
device here that monitor the pressure it
showed inside the mcgv valve
after that it will exit and then flow
out from the purge while this is the
purge valve
and then there will be a capillary
tubing connect between the push valve or
this arm
through your auto sampler
which is to this injection valve here
as long as the mixing already happens
when you are not running the equipment
after your sample analysis and yet you
did not flush your
instruments then they will start to have
salt along the line here
or even inside the palm head including
like palm sail or even inside all this
valve that connected to the pump head
and also to the capillary tubing
and then when you flow through the
capillary tubing
this is number one
there is an injection valve inside where
the switch
between the
bypass mode and the main password when
we said bypass meaning that they are
bypassing the needle the needle speed
and then the the solenoid will go
straight
uh into the column
bypass mode will only
happen when
the needle needs to lift up to draw the
sample
but
when the needles are not lifting up to
draw any samples
injection wire would be always in a main
path mode
main passport meaning that from number
one
in through the injection valve inside
this
rock there's a rotor field they will
flow through the rotor steel and then
came out and then go to this metering
device where they control the amount of
sample being drawn for the needle
and then the solenoid will then
pass through the needle leader seat
speed capillary back to the injection
valve
and then it will switch
to this point here
for to have the solvent to flow into the
column
internal parts of this injection box are
very small
imagine when you have precipitation stop
precipitation
inside the injection wire for the
capillary tubing or even the palm head
you will start to see a high back
pressure because of a very small
internal volume
so this could be the reason
why you see a higher back pressure and
it happens gradually
next we will look into
the hblc column
so the solvent that
flow out from this line
tubing here
into the hbrc column which is this part
this is also a very crucial component
that you need to take note of hbrc
column is the part where separation
happens
and also this is where the sample will
pass through
it is also the heart of the instrument
so this column has a very very small
particle size this small particular size
will require a flip
at both ends to protect the particles to
drop off from the column
so usually when there is a choke it will
happen at the fridge portion it's also
to protect the column
so that the contaminants contamination
go into the column
and also to protect the particles to
fall off the column but
because of this
width that's very small pore size it
will also
have the back pressure to build up
imagine when this fit at the head of the
column
is being saturated with the particles
the solvent can't flow through here
properly enhanced you will see high back
pressure when there is high back
pressure the flow into the column will
no longer be consistent
it will then affect your peak retention
time
and which ultimately your result may not
be consistent
there is no
recovery when the fleet is being choked
the only thing is that you need to
change a new column but how do i know
whether the problem is due to the column
or the
so first thing that you need to do is
you remove the column
when you remove the column the back
pressure drops down to the initial back
pressure when your instrument is new
it shows that the if the instrument is
fine
the problem is coming from the column
but when the back pressure is still high
even though you remove the column
meaning you said that the instruments
also having some precipitation along the
line or even
debris stuck along the line that caused
the high higher back pressure
comparing to when the instrument is at
the
optimal condition without the column
we'll just play a very important part
for the instrument just like our human
body
our
blood pressure usually you monitor your
blood pressure you want to make sure
that your blood pressure will not exist
which is harmful to your health
similarly hblc column hdlc system will
monitor bad treasure as well to
understand whether the instruments are
in good condition or not or even the
columns are in good condition
so when the column is choked you will
need to change it you can try to flush
it with high organic solvent it may or
may not help
yeah if it can't recover back to the
mutual pressure then you will need to
change your column
okay what if
due to the instrument means you have
eliminate the color by feel to the
instruments you will start to wonder
which part of the instrument that caused
the back pressure so how can you find
out which part of it that caused the
high back pressure the first thing what
you can do is you open the push valve
when you open the first valve
problem will not flow to the auto sensor
okay if you open the first wall
the back pressure drops
meaning to say that the palm
is all right there is no precipitation
happen inside because when you open the
first valve means the solvents are not
flowing into the auto sampler
and yet the pressure is low
and then it's the same as when it is at
the optimal conditions
during the pressure off is open
it shows that the pump
is in good condition no high back
pressure no precipitation
then you need to look into your auto
sampler because
when you open it the pressure drop but
when you close it the pressure build up
means blood pressure coming from auto
sampler but how do i know
in this open sampler which is the
portion that may cause the high back
pressure
what you can do is you can
disconnect the tubing one by one
first let me recap the flow of the
injection mouth
number one
which is here number one
is the flow of the solvent
through the injection valve number one
then from number one there is a group
inside transfer the solvent to number
two which is the next line
number two will have solvent to metering
device measuring device and exit through
the needle
which is here neither
neither seed
and then the soil will flow to port
number five which is here
from port number five there will be a
group in between to port number six
where the solvent will then go to the
column
so what you can do is that you start
losing from port number one so you trace
on one
two
four
five and six
so when you remove pot number one
the pressure drops
meaning that the back pressure are
coming from
the later shrimp meaning that it's
inside
inside the injection valve or needle or
needle tip because the pressure drops
so then you close it then you unscrew
number two
but what if you unscrew number two the
pressure didn't drop
human then high
means
now the solvents are not going
to the misery device means
never drop
meaning to say that
there may be a choke in the injection
valve
in this groove here
so you may want to consider to take this
group out to check or fornicate it or
change to a new one
but if let's say the pressure drops
meaning that it's not along the wall
here
it could be due to the needle or needle
fit
so when you unscrew it the pressure drop
means
it is safe along the group here and uh
the pump
then it could be due to the needle on
either side
neither is the part where usually sample
brings raw if your samples are very
crude cannot be dissolved in your mobile
phase
then you are stuck in it and what
happens is when you start inside
it will cause high back pressure
and then the sample that you are going
to draw in your following injection no
longer be consistent your av account
will get affected because the amount of
samples being draw are no longer
accurate
so you can also similarly as what i said
you can dismantle the last one 5 the
pressure drop
means it's not due to the upper part
here but the pressures still maintain
the same means it could be your needle
that is choked
yeah this is how you can try to find out
which part of the auto samplers that
cause the high back pressure
what i've said earlier is mainly by
testing on removing the
the the nuts
from each of the pot there's another way
that you can fly out to check whether
the
choke or the high back pressures are due
to the middle and little speed how can
you do that you can try out weight
bypass and name pass mode if you know
how to control your software by changing
the injection port
to bypass or main task mode
so in your software
there is this option where you right
click more option
you can see an option where you have
this called bypass
main path this is where you can hear
the switching of the injection one even
third
so it will switch in between bypass or
main path students in bypass mode means
the bypass leader and leadership when
it's in bypass mode
the project is good means low and
optimal meaning to say that
the choke are coming from neither any
that's it but when you switch to bypass
mode the project is still high meaning
the bypass and main path
bypass mode the pressure is still high
meaning to say that it is not due to the
needle or leadership or it could be you
don't need it that's it somewhere else
but the problems are still not dissolved
yet
these are the things that you can
consider bad pressure
due to salt precipitation are happened
on pump
back pressure due to need stuck at the
needle or needle teeth will be due to
stamper
always remember
sample will only be introduced into the
system from auto sampler
your center will not flow backwards to
your thumb
but
remember that any high back pressure in
the pump
is not due to the
sample because when the samples are
being introduced from the auto sampler
it will mix your mobile phase and go
straight to your
column for separation
and then to detector for detection
purposes
so that is an overview about high back
pressure
next we will go into the low back
pressures and pressure drop fluctuation
next we will look into pressure too low
for pressure too low commonly due to the
solvent inlet phase may be choked so
inside this solar bottle that is a
sovereign inner feed inside so when this
solvent in there fits a tower maybe with
algae or saw or any contaminants the
solvent that being drawn
through the through the tubing here uh
no longer be activated or they may have
bubbles or they may not able to draw any
solvent at all so when they can't draw
solvents you will see pressure too low
symptoms
other than that uh it could be due to
like um wrong flow rate wrong solvent so
sometimes you may use the wrong solvent
so you thought that it is the right one
then you realize someone the prejudice
is not right
that may be one of the reasons
besides that it could be due to the
pressure measurement so there is a
pressure sensor in your palm
in a palm head nearby the palm head area
or even an mcgv valve multi-channel
gradient wire there is a pressure sensor
if your pressure sensor is
40 meaning to say that it cannot detect
the right pressure and then it could it
could be one of the reason that gives
you low back pressure
other than that uh they may be due to
wow all the valve that is on the palm so
in your palm head just now initially i
mentioned that when the solenoid pass
through the pump the first valve that
they will pass through is called inlet
valve that's right the inlet of the
solvent to the palm head
so the inlet valve ah the valve will
control the
the solvent to pass through if the valve
is defective means they cannot control
the amount of solvent to flow into the
palm head then it will also cause
pressure too low similarly to the outlet
ball wow the exit of the forward
from the palm head to the damper or even
the purge valve so any of this valve is
defective it will also cause pressure
too low or pressure fluctuation
lastly it could be also column defective
because maybe the stationary phase or
bleed off no more stationary phase
or maybe less half of it then it could
be one of the reasons to cause low back
pressure
so pressure fluctuation is very rare but
many are
due to the
storage that have been drawn
um they cannot be drawn properly because
of the sovereign inlet freezer choke or
maybe the degasser
is faulty so the purpose of the gases is
to remove the gas in your solvent
imagine the gas cannot be removed
or but then now you cannot see any
bubble right at high back pressure you
will see bubble inside because there is
gas but when they pass through the
degasser the degasser will remove the
gas coming from the absorbers
and then when the solvents do not have
any gas at high flow rate high pressures
in the pump you will no longer have a
bubble symptom so when there is no
bubble you will not have pressure
fluctuation problem
of course uh outward bowel inlet was all
this may also
cause of the pressure fluctuation
so this is where you can try to slowly
step by step to find out what could be
the
cause of the fluctuating pressure
so you may have a question like was the
pump primed properly
if yes
then you can move on to your next
question like are you performing a
gradient analysis
if yes
maybe the pressure change follow the
gradient
that cause the pressure to change which
some people may say fluctuate but it is
normal because the changes are gradually
depending on the individual solvent
viscosity
but if it's no
then the next question you need to ask
yourself is are the palm head
functioning correctly
so if if it's not functioning correctly
then you need to do things like leak
test
usually how we want to find out whether
the system is okay besides looking at
pressure we can also perform some of the
diagnostic tests including harmless
tests or pleasure
prejudice and public tests can check uh
whether there's any physical lead
or internal leaks when you perform the
pump inlet
leak a pump liquid test because they are
checking based on the pressure whether
they can sustain the pressure at certain
time frame certain flow rate
to determine whether there's any
internal leaks in the time itself
and question you can also ask is like
are all the solvents being began
if yes then you need to ask whether are
they miserable
if it's no then you need to check the
miscibility but if it's yet
you also need to check whether are the
sovereign volatile
if the solvents are volatile yes then
you need to make sure the operating
temperature is suitable for this
sovereign use and degree of salvage
imagine if it's smaller now but yet the
temperatures in your environment is warm
maybe the problem will slowly get
evaporated off then the amount of
solvent or even are mixed with the
water's contents will no longer be the
same and that will also affect
the separation the retention time
because the forward the mobile phase the
play important part in helping the peak
separation
and then you can also ask questions like
is the pressure center working correctly
if yes means problem seems associated
with the pump
if if no
then
it could be due to
the pressure sensor problem and then you
may need to find out what is the
pressure difference and etc
next we will look into the auto sampler
troubleshooting this now what's about
palm now we're going to auto translate
troubleshooting usually the the problem
on auto samplers are more related to
fixed areas not reproducible
why in your auto sampler in the
injection port there's this water still
proton still has this phosphorus
means the injection valve itself the
group on this injection valve may
um leak
inside because of heat switching right
then you may have scratches the fracture
set is the part that causes the
crossport link
or even sometimes if the injection walls
are not tight enough there is some
internal leaks so all this link will
affect your peak area because the sample
being introduced into the column no
longer be consistent and sample amount
means the sample being produced will
affect the area count or maybe the
metering device
at the at the auto sample that shown
earlier that control the amount of the
sample being draw or maybe having some
leakage as well
so if let's say the metering device
fields are leaking
it will also affect the amount of sample
being drawn to be introduced into that
system or even columns a neither block
at all this also will affect the pit
area
how can you check
whether what kind
of the problems from the auto sampler
that affect this big area you can make
use of checking the peak area linearity
what do you what do i mean is that
you can inject different injection
volume and then you plot a calibration
curve to see whether this curve is
linear or not so you can start with like
0.5 mil
of the sample one meal of the temper two
mil of the sample three meal four meal
five mil so this is the injection volume
uh you draw this volume
and then you inject into the column when
the result is out then you plot to see
whether
the curve is linear
by right different injection volume the
area count should
increase gradually or even the peak
average should increase gradually and
that should give you a linear
curve if it's not linear
and because it's not linear
the it could be due to the rotor still
cross heart first port is lit
or injection valve is not tight metering
device fields are leaking or even
needles are partially blocked
this is a diagram of how the autosampler
works and also to show you that the
reproducibility problem that due to
aerial cows
are many are coming from
the
middle portion
so if you look at this seed area and
peak height mainly due to auto sampler
heat area and retention time mainly due
to the pump because the pump is the part
where it control the flow
the flow of the forward
the ratio of the solvent mixing
so what is the ratio of the organic
solvent and water content and this will
also affect the peak detention time
if you have problem with uh
reproducibility
especially the peak areas
yeah
what could be the reason so this is some
suggestion uh for you to refer to a
guideline but it's also similar to what
i've explained on the heart rate itself
initially
so a time of rule remember anything
related to peak area
heat height
due to auto sampler anything related to
retention tummy producibility
drive down to the pump
so
here are also another example giving you
an overview of the reproducibility in
terms of the retention time
so when you have decrease in retention
time
uh
what what could be the problem or when
you have uh
increasing in retention time or even
fluctuating in that what could be the
problem
so these are showing the inconsistency
how can you understand what condition
you need to do a pressure tracing
a flow measurement or even an injection
check to check the linearity
to make sure it's not due to the auto
sampler but it is due to the pump so you
need to isolate them one by one
here are further illustration based on
the three groups decreasing in retention
time
not not consistent or even
increasing so what could be the
possible cost
when you decrease in retention time
possible cost could be uh
the column is overload
yeah so you may want to reduce in the
amount of temperature to see whether it
helps to improve it
or maybe um the column stationary phase
starts to weigh out so that use of some
of the retention of this compound so
they get eluted out earlier
yeah because uh there's not much surface
in the columns an inter-stationary phase
able to retain your compound sometimes
it could be due to a
wrong
ph are being used
the stationary phase on the column was
slowly degraded especially when the
method that you use uh with very low ph
range
of the mobile phase
even wrong someone composition may also
cause the shift of the recharging time
towards the front
when there is a tool at the back
increasing of retention time
it could be also due to the mobile phase
uh it's definitely not due to the
way out of the column as long as when
the column is way out meaning that a
stationary phase is no longer able to
retain your samples that tends to exist
out earlier but when your compound is
out later is no longer due to your
column stationary phase
defect but it could be due to wrong
mobile phases are being used
or maybe the sovereign mixtures are not
correct
when it's related to someone mission not
correct you can think about whether is
it somewhere in the palm head
it's not working properly
or even wrong solvent composition yeah
or bubble and etcetera
or even fluctuating so fluctuating uh
could be due to the temperature
maybe you do not have a column r1 you
have your just column hanging outside
of the system so when your environment
temperatures are fluctuating if your
methods are very sensitive to
environment temperatures
then you will have a fluctuation in the
retention time especially when you are
solvent
those very volatile solvents at
different temperature the viscosity the
volatility all changes the flow of the
solvent changes
um the miscibility of the storm change
it will definitely affect your retention
time because solvent's characteristic
will change
at different
visibility volatility yeah
sometimes it could be due to your method
meaning the buffer use
capacity may not be sufficient
and it also could be due to your columns
are not being equipped
properly so you may if you are running a
gradient uh when you change to a
different gradient and then you need to
do a next injection but your color has
not
conditioned back to the initial uh
mobile phase ratio enough
then it will also give you
very produceable retention time
so
all this could be due to column and you
have a lot of fluctuations
you need to consider what could be the
cost of the columns based on what we
have suggested here it may not be due to
the instrument itself sometimes maybe
just change your column to another new
one it could help with the situation or
maybe you can flash the column more with
your initial solvent condition may also
help with the simulation
this is just a repeat of what i've
shared earlier through the instrument
especially when we produ retention time
is not reproducible what could be the
cause of it
followed by peak average not linear uh
it could be level possible metering
device here is just a more in-depth
diagram for you to refer to so that you
have a better idea um how it looks like
so here has a vertical the needle the
metering divides you these are the parts
that may cause the peak average not
linear not linear meaning that when you
increase the injection volume uh through
the column like one meal two meal
treatment formula you do not get a
linear curve
the signal noise is the structure of the
thickness over a short period of time
while the drift refers to the overall
change in the signal over a long period
of time is usually changed in either the
positive direction or negative direction
so above as a straight line under the
gesture thickness sometimes when your
lamp is weak means it's time to change
you will also have a drifting baseline
not a flat baseline yeah so this could
be the cause of it if the flow style is
dirty uh it will also have this kind of
a
noise uh problem so these are the
possible cause types from cell dirty
mobile physics is 30 and the lamp is
failing it's time to change
if you are using rid detectors they are
very sensitive to temperatures these are
the things that you need to take note
gradient illusions or even invisible
solvent
this is just a guide for you uh to find
out whether the baseline problem is due
to the palm
or due to the detector
so when there is a baseline noise you
stop your part means you don't need to
have a flow you put zero meal per minute
and then you monitor how the baseline
looks like
so if the baseline still perceives
means it is due to the detector because
now you already stopped the flow of your
palm you do not have any solvent coming
from the pump anymore
but when you off the
avenue when you're off the palm uh the
noise still resists it means a boy no
longer persists mistake
when you off the palm
uh no more flow
but uh the noise also resolved means
it's due to the pump maybe the mobile
phase is not clean
yeah then you need to check on it or
maybe there's some problem due to the
mobile phase compensation miscibility
and etc
sometimes uh
it could be also due to some mixing
problems uh like what you see on the
slides here
because of a uv detector so the uv
detector
will absorb the mobile phase ah
and then when you mix with those non-uv
absorbing mobile phase you will have
this kind of
problem
so what what is the solution to it add a
mixer to help with the mixing of two
different mobile phase
come together
postfix will be due to the column
contamination in the needle or needle
feet
yeah and lastly the sensitivity
could be due to the lamp is straight
time to change the lamp
when the flow cell is contaminated
you will also need to change it because
it will also
affect the sensitivity because the
lengths are being blocked so the light
can't shine through properly the
absorptions are not there then the
sensitivity of the pigment drop
other questions that you can ask
yourself have you changed your mobile
phase composition or
you may need to understand whether the
vendor
the mobile phase slot is changed and
that is that it could be one of the
cause
of this
detector problem you can also ask
yourself about have you changed your
acquisition wavelength what mobile phase
are last used in your instrument do you
have a misability problem are your
sovereign dirty these are the questions
that you can ask yourself when you come
to troubleshooting your
detector
lastly you must always exclude that
issue to applications before you really
uh go and check onto the instrument
sometimes if you never exit the
application and then you troubleshoot
spending a lot of time to troubleshoot
the instruments
and then lastly you finally do the
application you are actually spending a
lot of time just on the instrument
rather than a simple solution that is
due to some stepping on the application
so you need to take a methodol method
decal and systematic approach
localize the error in a part of the
system just like what i've shown earlier
you can unscrew
some uh
of the connections and then to check on
the back pressure always remember to
change one thing at a time
yeah don't change all night and i do not
know what is the root cause of it
ask for help whenever it's appropriate
plan the cost of action so whatever you
have changed note it down from the sop
so in future whoever still face the same
problem they can just base on the sop to
verify it and then to change it
accordingly
lastly
if today's session was worthwhile for
you and if you would like to have a
further learning from us we will offer a
wide range and cost effective training
course option to support you
and also to able to reach your goal we
offer three different type of education
staff including like classroom training
for those who ever attended our
classroom training i hope you enjoyed it
uh we also have virtual instructor leg
training similar to what i've shown
earlier so we have this uh theory and
then yet at the same time we will also
show on the instrument to give you have
a better idea but of course you can also
con
combine your virtual instructor-led
training with a hands-on training where
it happened in our lab here and we also
have a self-paced e-learning course so
when you go into our website you can
always uh
log in and then find out some of the
recorded online course
for your reading and understanding
before you decided to go for more
in-depth training in our site
here feel free to visit our agilent.com
training page for more details
we also have this uh course catalog for
your reference this is the qr code that
you can scan
and then it will lead you to our au
website
last but not least uh we will definitely
have more detailed training for you
wherever i shown here is some of the
review and tips and tricks for your
reference so uh we have like a course uh
technique or histology course
maintenance and troubleshooting course
cbs 2.x software course and also camp
station course feel free to contact us
anytime
for further
enquiry on the interested training
course
thank you for your attention
thank you joanne
now we will
go ahead and take some time for
questions now
just a reminder please be sure to type
your questions into the question box in
your control panel
also uh you will about to see simple
pulling questions on the screen
we appreciate your feedback on these as
well and we will give you a few seconds
for you to go through them
all right uh it looks like we have a few
questions
hey the first question is
uh to get optimum peak performance from
1200 uh i'm sorry yeah twelve hundred
and twelve uh 1260 series of hp lc
system what should be considered
joanne please thank you takashi thank
you takashi
you need to make sure that your sample
preparation is adequate to the hvlc
and you also must make sure that you use
hvlc great water
always filter your solvents before you
use it
and one thing that you must consider is
the misability of the solvents
especially if you are using salt buffer
you need to ensure that the salt mix
well
in your water and also when the solvent
and water are mixed together during your
gradient run
at any
percentage concentration the salt will
still be mixing
well miserable well in the solvent
itself
before you perform any sample analysis
you need to also push your hplc system
with the mobile phase equip your column
and stabilize the column r1 temperature
and check the detector
to ensure a stable baseline before you
start any run
okay great
the second question
what is the uh the frequently replaced
consumable strength pump maintenance
as shown earlier in also the video the
slides
usually when you perform palm
maintenance the main thing that we
change is palm seals and frizz these are
very common consumables that you need to
change every half yearly
it also depending on how frequent you
use your instrument if your instrument
is heavily used it is recommended to
change even
every three months
the palm sales is the part that when
it's in the palm you easily
get way out because it's a wear and tear
consumables
and also the fridge that is located in
the purge while it will get choked
easily because you actually filter off
uh any contaminants from your mobile
face if your mobile phase is not pure
enough the feet will get choked
more frequently
so besides replacing palm seals and
sweet you will also need to clean the
piston and the internal palm head area
ensuring that there is no scratches and
free of salt precipitation
in addition to it you will also need to
clean and replace the outlet and inlet
valve
the
consumables that i've shown earlier in
the video
some you can consider to sonicate it um
if let's say it's true but after
sonication if it's still not usable then
you will need to change the valve
thank you
okay thank you very much joanne there's
more questions
okay i'm currently having trouble with
the linearity test and i don't think the
problem is hplc itself could it be
possibly because of the type of sample
vial
sample while possible
um
i need to look at the
chromatogram itself and what has been
happened
for this analysis
so what um
it could be due to sample was especially
the scepter because um
the scepter of the sample wells may have
reactions with your samples that affect
the linearity but first of all we need
to
separate these two
things to check it out whether is it
sample valves method itself
or the instrument
so if you still recall that the video
that i've shared earlier
first of all i will need to check the
linearity
by checking on the autosamplers is
performing well where i inject different
injection volume
of a standard checkout standard so i
inject one microlite two microarray
three microwave up to five to check
whether i get a linear curve
so if let's say
the curve is linear 99.99
of the
um the coefficients
efficiency and
means that the instruments are
not an issue with a standard checkout
standard
albeit a standard column
then
if this happens only on the samples that
you're running
or even on a particular column that
you're running
then it could be due to some reaction of
the sample via sample valves or it could
be due to your column so
we need to troubleshoot it step by step
first
isolate whether is it due to instrument
problem if the instruments are in good
conditions then you move on to check on
whether is it due to column
or your sample wells if you suspect is
due to sample buffs
yeah
thank you okay
thank you joanne
there's another question
what is an ideal equilibrating time
before running at starting conditions of
your method
thank you takashi so for the
equilibration time it's very
it is very depending on what mobile
phase you are using
for that method
so imagine your this method um
is not a simple reverse phase kind of
mode methods for hplc meaning that it
requires some ionic strength where your
mobile phase
contains some soft buffer like phosphate
buffer
or even some acid like um acidic acid
or acetic acid so when you have um all
these additives in your mobile phase
your column will need to equate long
enough because
the column
the the stationary phase in your columns
need to be in the conditions
where
it has been treated by the mobile phase
so the equilibration time is very varies
also vary depending on the length of
your column
imagine if you are using a 250
centimeter column
very long and also the id is
big 4.6 mm
then you will need a longer time
it could be a two three hours
or if let's say you are using a very
small column like um 50 centimeter
and you are using a small id
probably 2.1 mm id
the equilibration time
definitely will be lower
so it varies
based on
the method
you are running because the mobile phase
that you are running
is a crucial to the time needed to
equilibrium column
and it also vary depending on the
column dimension
so you will need to re-look into your
method
what mobile phase you are using
and then um
of course not just that
when you develop a new method you
actually tested with different condition
you will start with
um one hour whether it is sufficient one
and a half hour whether it is sufficient
sometimes it may be only 30 minutes so
it really depends on what method you are
using
so for simple basic methods normal
reverse phase just acetonitrile and
water
15 minutes to 30 minutes is sufficient
if let's say your methods contain a lot
of salt buffers and the column is
very long
it could take
one hour to two hours for every
equilibrations
especially i understand if you run
gradients
when you are back
to the next injections your gradients at
a different mobile phase and then you
need to go back to the original
conditions then it takes like one two
hours which uh pretty time consuming so
that's why a lot of
customers they're actually looking into
a shorter column because they
shortened the equation time
and
of course they look into how to optimize
that method to make it better
thank you
okay
it looks like we have one more question
so we still have a little bit of time so
let's do this one as well
is the ripple value the only indicator
of a stable baseline equivalent
okay so for the vapor value it's not the
only indicator
we
also need to look at the pressure
pressure of the systems
what is the back pressure
so if let's say your back pressure is
very high
they also show that the systems is not
at the optimal conditions
so beside reaper
you look at the pressure
and
yeah sometimes uh the compressibilities
may affect the vapor so
the reaper is
one of the indicator
but
not the
the
okay uh it looks like a joanne is having
some technical issues uh we apologize
about that
um
we will contact you
separately offline uh to answer the
question we were going through at the
last at the very end
so uh
we'd like to wrap up this session
and thank you everyone for uh we
appreciate you being here today
and please take a look around the
virtual site uh visit our booth breakout
room and software center to download the
latest product consumables and services
information
also on demand contents are available in
auditorium
please check them out if you have missed
any of the past sessions
and we also would like to have your
feedback please complete our general
survey in the lobby of the virtual site
thank you again for joining us today and
we will see you next time